merci beaucoup pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas hélas pas pu y en a un
qui connaît dans cette salle en tout cas
c'est georges georges fenech mon ami
député du rhône ce rillieux-la-pape
c'est une ville de la banlieue lyonnaise
trente mille habitants 57 % de logements
sociaux
il y est au mieux de cette ville une
jupe qui existe depuis les années 60 qui
n'a pas évolué ce que mes prédécesseurs
socialistes ne l'ont pas n'ont pas peiné
n'ont pas voulu bénéficier de l'anru en
tout cas très peu dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a tout un retard à rattraper
et dans cette jupe ses dix-huit mille
habitants autant dire deux tiers de la
population pour plus de 80% logements
sociaux
autant dire que les problèmes de
sécurité d'incivilités et de
tranquillité publique je connais fait
que renault tu connais un petit peu
aussi à aulnay on est arrivé sur une
situation où tout allait à vau l'eau
une police municipale en baisse on avait
plus que 12 policiers municipaux pour
tentes mille habitants mon prédécesseur
pour montrer à quel point les caméras de
vidéoprotection était inutile les avait
placés à des endroits qui ne filmaient
pas avec personne derrière
donc quand il a fallu quand nous avons
nous sommes arrivés aux responsabilités
et dernière nous avons dû prendre ce
problème à bras le corps parce qu'il y
avait un vrai problème et tout n'est pas
encore fini
nous avons été la première police
municipale en france à s'équiper de ces
fameuses petites caméras de
vidéoprotection portative en l'espace
noûn je les ai généralisée en juillet
en l'espace de quelques mois nous avons
fait baisser les outrages à agents lors
des contrôles notamment parce que les
policiers municipaux doivent aller au
contact en tout cas ses choix que nous
avons faits rillieux la pape
ils doivent aller au contact et il faut
qu'ils sécurisent nous avons fait
baisser les outrages à agents de plus de
80% ça veut dire que ça marche
par contre nous avions un flou juridique
qui existe toujours d'ailleurs
le problème de ce flou juridique c'est
que nous avons le parquet qui nous a dit
oui mal an maintenant va falloir nous
expliquer comment vous faites donc le
parquet avant de savoir pourquoi on se
sent sécuriser nos policiers municipaux
nous a demandé oui mais ce que c'est
bien légal de l'est sur données de les
sécuriser parce que ce dispositif les
sécurise avant tout parce qu'une
spécialité dans les villes de banlieue
c'est quand policier municipal raconte
elle au contact mais un policier
national on l'insultent pour le bouscule
mais par contre j'ai des parents des
fois nos petits voyous qui sont dans les
halls d'immeuble qui viennent nous voir
nous en monsieur le maire vous rendez
compte c'est un scandale
mon fils était embarqué par votre police
on l'a plaquée au sol voilà alors que
cette personne là est en général dans
une commune de banlieue on n'a pas
quarante y en a pas il n'y a pas
cinquante mille personnes qui font des
troubles bruno je pense en tant que
maire d'une ville de banlieue peu le
peut en parler aussi bien que moi c'est
en général entre 50 et 100 personnes
maximum
c'est toujours les mêmes ça c'est la
première chose deuxième chose
développement de la vidéoprotection de
façon massive création d'un centre
superviseur urbain avec du monde
derrière doublement des effectifs de
police municipale vrai travail en
relation avec la police nationale avec
fréquence de radio commune on n'a pas
attendu que le ministre de l'intérieur
met les acropole à disposition avec ça
en l'espace d'un an et demi on a moins
20% de délinquance sur la ville de
rillieux la pape
les dégradations volontaires c'est le
chiffre le plus impressionnant qu'on a
réussi à voir son passé ont baissé en
l'espace de 2 me sur la même période de
janvier 2014 à août 2014 donc sur la
même période en 2015 on a baissé de plus
de 54%
je parle pas de 10 on est passé à quatre
on est passé de son épouse est partie de
donc ça veut dire que si on met ces ces
éléments en place ça fonctionne le
problème par contre aujourd'hui et
bernard l'a très bien dit bernard reynès
l'a très bien dit c'est la mission le
statut de la police municipale
aujourd'hui on a des policiers
municipaux qui face à certains faits
sont complètement démunis et en plus le
parquet ne va pas forcément suivre ils
doivent parfois pour agir demander
l'avis à l'officier de police judiciaire
qui en général se trouve soit la
gendarmerie ce haut commissariat le vrai
problème qu'on a par exemple notamment
dans les quartiers c'est la consommation
de cannabis
par exemple la consommation de drogue
qu'est ce qui se passe quand un policier
municipal arrive va dans un hall
d'immeuble
on voit qu'il ya déjà un regroupement et
qu'en plus il s'enquit à l'utilisation
de peaux de produits stupéfiants déjà
premièrement il peut simplement faire
une palpation de sécurité
s'il veut fouiller un individu doit
demander l'autorisation un officier de
police judiciaire
deuxièmement s'il s'avère que certaines
personnes sont en possession de produits
stupéfiants
on doit mettre à disposition de l'office
police judiciaire le contrevenant et il
ya ce qu'on appelle une procédure
simplifiée procédure simplifiée grosso
modo si on vous confisque là on vous
confisque le produit stupéfiant d'accord
et la personne a simplement un rappel à
la loi
moi je pense qu'à un moment il faut
qu'on aille qu'on soit un peu plus malin
dans le dispositif parce que clairement
cette procédure simplifiée ça veut dire
que quand vous tapez simplement sur les
dons vous dis c'est pas bien d' art
consommé de la drogue
au revoir ce qu'il faudrait c'est que la
police municipale aujourd'hui puissent
verbaliser mais de façon très lourde
quand je dis très lourdes ça veut dire
que la transaction lui d'être faite
entre le pgi comme ceole comme c'est
prévu dans les prochains textes entre
loupé j ai le parquet il faut que ça
soit possible entre la police municipale
et le parquet devienne meilleure
réactivité on encombre pas le travail
des op j mais en plus derrière si une
personne consomme du cannabis et que
vous commencez à taper au portefeuille
je pense que ça va beaucoup plus porté
ses fruits que faire simple un simple
rappel à la loi donc pareil sur les
procédures de contrôle routier j'ai un
exemple il ya pas très longtemps sur un
exemple de contrôles routiers si vous
êtes dans le délictuelle en termes
d'alcoolémie ou de défaut de permis de
conduire une police municipale ne peut
pas sanctionner directement
il faut qu'elle passe par un officier de
police judiciaire encore là et encore
une fois on obstruent le travail de la
police nationale
c'est toutes ces choses là qui va
falloir qu'on imagine pour donner encore
un peu plus de marge de manoeuvre au
maire encore un peu plus d'efficacité à
la police municipale parce que c'est
vrai que de toute façon le maire a un
rôle et doit garder un rôle central dans
la sécurité de de la sécurité la
tranquillité publique au niveau de sa
commune je vais pas être beaucoup plus
longue en tout cas on a vraiment
là-dessus un enjeu qui est fort c'est
essayer justement d'ouvrir ses
compétences des policiers municipaux
pour que dans leur mission ils soient
beaucoup plus à l'aise la réactivité des
sanctions soient plus rapides et en tout
cas qu'on ait une meilleure efficacité
sur la tranquillité publique et c'est
vrai que bernard l finalement tu as
très bien résumé les choses il faut
vraiment aujourd'hui peut-être que
demain on arrive à séparer la sécurité
de la tranquillité qui sont deux choses
différentes
parce qu'en terme de sécurité on sait
que c'est du régalien et ça ne les
maires nous on est un peu démuni par
rapport à ça on n'a pas les moyens de
l'état en termes de tranquillité les
maires nous sommes en première ligne
et c'est nous qui sommes un peu les
généralistes de notre commune et sur ces
communes en tout cas qui sont sensibles
on peut être encore sollicité beaucoup
plus merci alexandre